what you're seeing in the uk at the
moment and over the last year or so
you've seen uh for the first time in
more than a decade you're seeing
increases in wages which is what we
wanted to see and uh when you talk about
uh some of the the supply chain issues
that's really a function of the the
world economy the particularly the uk
economy coming back to life after covid
sucking in gas in particular there's
massive demand for that in in asia
there's a shortage of lorry drivers
actually around the world from poland to
the united states even in china they're
short of
lorry drivers and
what we want to see is a high-wage
high-skill economy where we invest in
people investing fantastic
infrastructure like this behind me and
and drive high productivity growth
that's the that's the model we should be
going for but are you worried about the
pain and aren't you really blaming
business for
all of this
i think that what we're seeing is the
recovery of the economy we've now got
the fastest growing economy in the g7
and i think that you you've got
unemployment way way lower than people
forecast you've got jobs being created
the whole time and what we want to see
are high wage high wager high skilled
jobs and i think business is doing a
fantastic job of now investing in
apprentices of investing in in skills
and that's the way to go for the uk uh
we and
on things like the road haulage industry
that the thing to do is to make the job
more attractive invest in the truck
stops and and and invest in higher wages
as well if all electricity is going to
come from renewables yes it is by 2035
does that mean you're saying there will
be no new coal and no new oil and gas
from now what i'm saying is that we can
do for our entire energy production by
2035
what we're doing with uh internal
combustion engine vehicles uh by 2030.
so from from 2030 uh you won't be able
to buy any more a new hydrocarbon fueled
uh internal combustion engine
car
and we're going to move to either to evs
or to vehicles powered by hydrogen or
clean power clean power of one kind or
another and that'll make a huge
difference to
our co2 output to controlling climate
change to the planet but it will also
put the uk at the forefront of
this amazing new industry of clean
vehicles and what we're also saying is
that by 2035 looking at the progress
that we're making uh in wind power where
we lead the world now in offshore wind
looking at what we can do with other
renewable sources carbon capture
and storage uh with with hydrogen
potentially
we think we can get to uh
complete clean energy production by
2035. now the advantage of that to go
back to your earlier question anushka is
that it will mean that for the first
time the uk is not dependent on
hydrocarbons coming from overseas with
all the vagaries in hydrocarbon prices
and the risks that poses for people's
pockets and for the consumer will be
will be will be reliant on our own clean
power generation which will be which
will help us also to keep costs down
prime minister yesterday you told us
that the most important thing we needed
to do was trust the police we've woken
up today and another serving police
officer has been charged with rape women
are rightly terrified why won't you make
it explicit in the policing bill that
agencies and authorities must treat
domestic abuse and sexual violence as a
violent crime
first of all on the case that you
mentioned anushka it's an ongoing case
uh somebody has been charged i can't
comment on the detail of that and that
will clearly have to go through but what
we can certainly conclude from the wayne
cousins case and what happened there is
that there is a massive job of work to
do to
give women the confidence that they need
and i i want to be clear i believe that
people should be confident in the police
i think that police officers men and
women up and down the country will be
absolutely sickened by what has happened
and and they and they will be doing
everything they can and i know they do
everything they can to help and to
reassure the public so it is vital that
the public trust the police but what we
need to do is do some things to make the
streets safe and we're investing
massively in uh in cctv and street
lighting and
and those sorts of things but also make
sure that we change the culture of
policing and your point is a very good
one the police officers need to handle
these cases properly to take them
seriously and i want to see a much
shorter time between a reporting of a
crime an arrest between an arrest and a
prosecution and a prosecution and a
conviction we've got to contract all
that we've also got to recruit many more
female police officers it's happening in
the met up to 40 now if new recruits are
female it should happen around the
country
and finally are you concerned your party
isn't doing enough to vet who is giving
donations to you i see that uh story
again today but all i can say on that
one is that all these donations are are
vetted in the in the normal way in
accordance with rules that were actually
set up under under the labour government
so uh we vet them the whole time